في كل مرة يظهر فيها مريض في
غرفة الطوارئ مع أي نوع من الأعراض ،
فإن الطريقة التي يجب أن يعالج بها هذا الشخص
هي أن
مقدمي الرعاية الصحية يرتدون
معدات الحماية الشخصية لفحص ذلك المريض
لأنهم لا يعرفون هل هذا الشخص
لديه كوفا  19:00 لديك فيروس كورونا
هذا أم لا ، عليك أن تفترض
أنهم يفعلون في نفس الوقت ما
نسمعه أننا نسمع أنه وفقًا
لبعض البيانات المبكرة في الصين ، فإن أربعة
من كل خمسة أشخاص تم
تشخيصهم لاحقًا  اكتسب كرونو فيروز
تلك العدوى من شخص لم يكن
يعلم أنه مصاب بها ، دعني أكرر
أن أربعة من كل خمسة أشخاص أصيبوا
بعدوى إيجابية بفيروس كورونا حصلوا
عليها من شخص لم يكن يعلم أنهم مصابون
به ، لذا فنحن لا نفعل ذلك.  لا أعلم أنك يجب أن
تفترض أن أي شخص ربما يكون لديه
هذا ، ولهذا السبب نحن نبتعد اجتماعيًا في
حياتنا في المستشفى ، ليس لديك
هذا الخيار ، عليك أن تعتني
بطبيب مريض بينما لدينا
هنا فقط أخبر  كيف كان الأمر
بالنسبة لك في الأيام القليلة الماضية ، ما الذي
شاهدته من حيث عدد المرضى
والفئة العمرية للمرضى الذين
تعالجهم ، أنت تعرف جون أنا سعيد لأنك
تسأل هذا لأننا نرى  نعم
بالطبع نحن نرى الأشخاص الأكبر سنًا
يعانون من مشاكل في الجهاز التنفسي ، لكننا
نرى الكثير من الأشخاص في الثلاثينيات
والأربعينيات من العمر والأصغر سناً الذين يأتون
بمستويات الأكسجين لديهم منخفضة قليلاً ،
حيث ترتفع معدلات ضربات قلبهم.  مريض
وبعضهم يتم قبوله وفي جميع
أنحاء البلاد أرى أشخاصًا في الأربعينيات من العمر يستخدمون
أجهزة التنفس الصناعي لفترات طويلة من
الوقت لم يسمع بها من قبل لا نرى عادةً
أنه
إذا كنت سأفحص جاري ،
فستكون أفضل ممارساتي هي الضغط على
الباب ثم تراجع مسافة أربعة أقدام على الأقل
إن لم يكن ستة أقدام حتى لا
يكون لدينا أي فرصة وجهًا لوجه
لانتقال الفيروس ،
فنحن نعلم أن مشاعر العزلة تعرض
الأشخاص للخطر أو تعرض الكثير من العوامل
النفسية والعكسية.  نتائج الصحة البدنية
بوت  يذوب الماء الذي يذوب السلع المعلبة ،
لقد كنت تعرف شيئًا ما كنت
أركز عليه حقًا أنا في عطلة الربيع ، لذلك
اعتقدت أنه يمكنني التخلص من مؤخرتي
والقيام ببعض الشيء بنفسي ، أود أن أشجع
الناس على إرسال رسائل وكتابة ملاحظات
تنزلق فيها  صناديق بريد الأشخاص أو تحت
أبوابهم تتصل بالعائلة والأصدقاء
وخلال هذا الوقت يكون الأمر أكثر أهمية
من أي وقت مضى لأننا نمارس المسافات الاجتماعية
التي نبقى على اتصال مع
بعضنا البعض
.
لقد أخذ Schad بشريًا كوبرا 81 مليونًا
محنة أخرى ، إنها طاولة
أميبية ، فريق لذيذ أعني بقلم ناهين مارا هو
لامدا ك دونالد ترامب من طعامنا بالفندق
SL holla بعيدًا اجتماعيًا ،
سأحصل على HTML الذي هو لانكا unil
رئيس وشيك شارون  يحل الفيروس بطريقة متقطعة ،
المحلل خان يكون مثالي الذي
حصل عليه من Shara
well alaikum عالم النبات الذي تخيله
- تصور نبيل أن فاتورة Lama Yeshe
مصممة في خطة إدارة Cara Lynn
ولكن كعنصر أميركي نبيل سيكون
في الغالب ahima إنه رجل مقدس
أو  هي بشكل عام تكون سييرا جيدًا
- حول منطقة فريق الطبق هنا ، وضعت
ساطورًا لتعوي معجبًا بالعجلة في
منطقة تطور العائلة ، كانت هنا في
SS هنا
جيدًا ، إنها مجرد نفسي في كوالا
في سانتا خون
سيثا كادام لقد  't aDNA bananas Howard آخر
LM لا يستطيع جيل لديه روح الدعابة حول الفيلم
الثماني الذي يشيد بالحناء البلطي
الخيري سلامة حسنًا رجل جهادي شرير
هنا إلى القدس هناك
لحن جديد يمشي والحج  أنا
مصل يبيع مرضًا عقليًا معدنيًا ASEA ،
نعم ، عليك أن تشيرنوبيل هو ضرر
فضلات أبراهام لذلك نأمل من القطن
لكن كيرا أوينز الماس
الغامض في tozi لم يذكر أنه يجب أن يقدم لك
الواقع العام الخروب ويلما -
القرفة
Laveranues uvula te  رأى لكن الفيروس البشري
في الخضار كان لديه صدق موسيلين قابل للإصلاح ،
لذا فإن ميكانيكيًا في Waterloo Maha Maha
Braille أكثر سخونة أو يبيعه - آسف
يا O'Hara أنت من المشاهير المال له